President Trump is spending more time  away from the White House mr. Trump who  is jetted down to his home in Florida  several times since becoming president  and spending the weekend this weekend  and his home in New Jersey president  says this cuts the cost of his  taxpayer-funded security detail in half  compared with staying at Trump Tower  here in New York Margaret Brennan has  the story we're a very small town with a  small budget Bedminster Mayor Stephen  Parker serves a town of eight thousand  two hundred residents including the  President of the United States he's been  a good member of the community blind  look and the second highest